[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAREN: I'd like to
welcome Julia Turshen.
She's a longtime friend of mine,
and she's a writer and recipe
developer.
In addition to her
newly-published solo effort,
"Small Victories,"
Julia has coauthored
such bestselling cookbooks
as "Spain: A Culinary Road
Trip with Mario
Batali," "It's All Good"
with Gwenyth Paltrow, as
well as "Mastering Mistakes
in the Kitchen," "The Kimchi
Chronicles," "Hot Bread
Kitchen," "The
Fat Radish Kitchen
Diaries," and "Buvette."
She also hosted the first two
seasons of "Radio Cherry Bomb,"
which is a podcast.
And Julia is famous for
using simple techniques
to demonstrate how small
victories in the kitchen
can help you become
a confident cook.
So we are very excited to
have her here at Google
to show us all how it's done.
With that, I'll hand
it over to Julia.
JULIA TURSHEN: Thanks, Karen.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I think Karen left out--
she said we're old friends,
but Karen's my oldest friend.
We met in the third grade, and
we've been friends ever since.
So this is just great to
be here in its full circle.
And I'm just so happy
to meet all of you.
So I have this new
book, "Small Victories,"
which I think you're all
gonna get a copy at the end.
It came out yesterday.
I'm super excited about it.
This is my first
time talking about it
in front of anyone but a
mirror, so this is awesome.
So I thought I'd tell you
a little bit about the book
and a little bit about the
recipe that I'll demonstrate.
And then we can eat
some of the recipe,
and I would love to answer any
questions you guys might have.
So my first question
is how-- see,
if I worked at Google, I don't
think I would maybe ever cook,
because you guys have
such amazing food.
But how many of
you cook at home?
Oh, that's awesome.
OK, cool.
OK, so I'm talking to home
cooks, so that's great.
So "Small Victories,"
the title is
the same as just the whole
concept of the cookbook.
And it's basically
approaching food sort
of thinking about
small victories, which
I think of as like
tips or techniques that
make cooking really
approachable,
really let you be,
like, an intuitive cook,
and just make it really fun.
And so every recipe
in the book is
introduced by, like,
a small victory, which
is this tip or
technique, and then
every recipe is followed by a
bunch of spin-offs, which are,
like, variations.
So once you know the
tip or technique,
you can make the thing, but
you can also make x, y, and z.
So it's sort of
thinking about cooking
in this very
exponential way, which
I feel like is kind of-- to me,
there's some sort of synthesis
with everything you
guys do at Google,
and it's like this
one thing, but it
can be so many other things.
So I was gonna demonstrate the
turkey and ricotta meatballs
today, which are--
honestly, I feel
like choosing a favorite
recipe from the book,
it's like asking someone to
choose their favorite kid
or something.
Like, I just-- I can't.
But this might be it.
And they're especially
special to me
because they were
the first thing
I made for my wife, Grace.
And she had told me about--
she had just recently, right
before we met, she
had eaten these--
I think they were
veal and ricotta
meatballs at a restaurant.
She said they were so great.
And I was like, oh my god,
like, I love this girl,
I want to impress her.
So I was like, I'm gonna
try to make something.
And so I the first
thing I ever brought
to her apartment, which became
our apartment, was my pot.
So that's what I brought over.
And I made her these meatballs.
And anyway, we got
married really soon after.
So I feel like-- I don't promise
lifelong love or marriage,
but it worked for me, so
I highly recommend it.
So we-- I mean, whatever.
Like, it can't hurt, right?
So the sort of small victories
in this recipe are a few.
One is that I-- the
meatballs are really simple
and they don't take
that many ingredients.
And I'm gonna combine
turkey with ricotta
because, as my
mother-in-law recently
said to me, because she made
these, turkey, let's face it,
is always dry.
But it's a nice sort of
leaner, healthier option.
And I think adding
ricotta to it makes
them just not dry and
really sort of succulent
in this great way, and in a
way that sort of beef and pork
can be that turkey isn't always.
And it also happens to make the
meatballs totally gluten-free,
if it's important to you or
the people you're cooking for,
because you can-- by
adding the ricotta,
you can skip the
eggs and bread crumbs
that are normally in meatballs,
which is kind of nice.
And then I just pack them
with a bunch of herbs.
So we're gonna make them, and
then the simplest tomato sauce.
And the other small victory
is that I bake the meatballs
instead of pan-frying
them because it's just
so much easier.
It's a lot less mess.
You're not, like, cleaning
up, like, a spattered stovetop
and everything.
So those are some of
the small victories.
And then in the
book, you'll see you
can turn-- once you know
how to make these meatballs,
you can take those
techniques and make
so many different kinds.
So actually my wife Grace runs
amazing website, Design Sponge.
And this week, I'm doing all
these posts on lunchbox meals.
So yesterday, we did,
like, a turkey merguez
meatball with, like, cumin and
harissa and flavors like that.
So if you change the
ingredients or change the sauce,
you can really have
this whole other thing.
So it's just great.
So I'm gonna start mixing them.
But then I was hoping maybe
to get a couple of volunteers
to help me roll them.
But first, I'm
gonna wash my hands.
But if there's anyone who might
be interested in rolling them,
you can also-- there's sinks
there, or you can use this one.
We've got some
gloves if you'd like.
But I'll just walk
you through them,
because they're super easy.
I also love
meatballs because you
can make a huge batch
of them and keep
them going for a while.
And all the recipes
in the book-- I'm
just gonna throw
that right there.
All the recipes in the
book for the most part
just serve four people,
but this one I purposely
did a double batch because
I always make extra,
so I figured most
people would want to,
because who doesn't
want meatballs
in the fridge at any point.
So it starts with
just ground turkey.
I definitely prefer
dark meat for this,
just because it's got a
lot more fat and moisture
and those things that just
make them taste really good.
And then we have ricotta
cheese, which is just
whole milk ricotta cheese.
So I'm just gonna add that.
And then it really
helps if you have
someone like Marion, who's
gonna chop up everything for you
first.
It makes it super easy.
I highly recommend that.
And then we're gonna do-- this
is just chopped fresh parsley.
And I love it because it
gives them a lot of flavor,
but also color, and they
look nice and fresh.
This is chopped basil.
Add all of it?
Yeah.
OK.
It's all portioned.
Awesome.
I have to take you everywhere.
I'm so excited.
And then this is
some grated Parmesan,
which I'm putting in them, and
will also put on them later,
because it just-- Parmesan
makes everything better,
so why not put it in and on
top, because life is short,
and it should be full of cheese.
And some chopped fresh garlic.
Same thing.
And some salt.
So I just washed my
hands for probably, like,
the fifth time
today, and I think
hands are the best
tool for this job,
so I just mix it with my hands.
But if you're kind
of like, I'm not
so into touching,
like, raw meat,
you can totally just do this
with one big mixing spoon.
And that is literally it.
Like, that's all you need
to do to make this mixture.
And then we're just
gonna roll them into-- I
like to do kind of, like,
golf ball-sized meatball-- hi,
Jenny Posen.
How are you?
And-- but you can make
them really, like, small,
like little polpettini, or
you can make larger ones,
like a big softball-sized
meatball, if you want.
I guess that gets you
into meatloaf territory,
but there's nothing
wrong with that.
So as you can see, they
have a lot of-- you know,
they're sort of as
green as they are pink.
And I just-- I love having
that many fresh herbs.
And anyway, so is anyone
interested in rolling?
Yeah.
Oh, awesome.
Amazing.
OK, this is gonna
go really fast.
So if you guys want
to come up here,
one thing that Marion
took out, which I love,
is that ice cream scoop.
And that means you can get
really evenly-sized meatballs,
which is awesome.
But you can also just
kind of freeform it.
They don't have to be,
like, super perfect.
I'm a big fan of food that's,
like, not totally perfect.
I really just-- I
love homemade stuff
just in general, and in theory.
So anyway, so if you
guys want to help me out,
we can use this, or just, you
know, do it about that size.
Yeah, go for it.
And--
AUDIENCE: Just go
right in there?
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah, go for it.
And we'll roll them
out and put them here.
Yeah.
You can use that if you like.
And maybe while you guys
are rolling those out,
I'm gonna walk you
through the tomato sauce
that, after we
bake the meatballs,
they're gonna just
simmer in the sauce.
You can also-- like, my really
close friend Larry, he has,
like-- I hope he doesn't
mind me saying this.
He's got, like, bad acid
reflux kind of stuff.
Like, a lot of people have that.
So you can skip the sauce.
You can just bake the meatballs,
eat them on their own.
They're delicious.
There's a lot of flexibility.
I really feel like
recipes, like, they
tend to be sort of
seen as and treated
as kind of
prescriptions, like you
have to do this exact thing.
And I totally
don't believe that.
I feel like you can
make them anything.
It's your kitchen,
it's your meal.
Make it work for
whatever your needs are.
But I love tomato sauce, and I
think they're delicious in it,
so we're gonna make this.
And it's honestly like-- just--
it'll take, like, 10 seconds.
And don't blink,
because you'll miss it,
because it's super simple.
So I'm just gonna turn this on.
Did I do it right?
Oh, no.
Yeah.
OK, great.
And then all it is is a
little bit of olive oil.
And then this is
perfectly sliced garlic,
because I didn't slice it.
And once this gets
a little bit hot,
I'm gonna add this, and the
oil kind of like-- I always
think of it, it kind of,
like, blooms the garlic.
It starts to sizzle, and it
just gets all that great flavor.
So I'm gonna let it get
hot so it can do that,
and then we're gonna
add-- these are canned
whole tomatoes, which I like to
crush before just so you don't
get, like, a huge tomato.
But if you like
really smooth sauce,
you could run them
through a blender
or use, like, an immersion
blender, a food mill.
You know, whatever
device you have.
But I kind of like,
again, like the sort
of imperfect perfect meatballs.
Like, I like a little bit
of texture in the sauce,
so I like to just crush them
with a hand-- with my hands
and put them in a big bowl.
And that's-- I don't know if
any of you have kids or are
thinking about it or are
on your way like Karen,
but it's a really great
job for kids to do,
like to get in a big bowl of
tomatoes and, like, crush them.
It feels like, oh my god,
I get to make a mess.
And-- but like, it's
for a good purpose.
So that's always great.
So this seems nice and hot.
This is way better
than my stove at home.
So I just added that garlic.
And I think you guys
can see-- I'm not sure.
But I'll face it this way.
When I add garlic
to oil in a pan,
I always kind of tilt the
pot so that the garlic
can kind of, like, fry in it.
And obviously, if you
had a ton of olive oil,
you wouldn't need to do that.
But this way, you don't
have to add, like, so much
fat to what you're making.
So just kind of get it till
it's, like, really nice
and fragrant.
And this, to me, is just
the best smell in the world.
I don't think there's really
much better than that.
Oh my god, they did it.
That's amazing.
OK.
So we're gonna add the tomatoes.
And just maybe not wear, like,
your favorite white shirt
when you do this.
That's my only advice.
And those go in.
And I am just gonna
add a bit of salt.
And tomatoes definitely
love salt, so don't be shy.
And basically, this
comes to a boil.
And once it does
that, I'm gonna turn
the heat down a little bit.
And that is tomato sauce.
So tomato sauce is something
a lot of people buy in a jar.
It usually is, like, filled with
sugar and preservatives and all
this stuff.
Fine if you like those
things, but if you don't, it's
really-- like to me, this
is the most delicious sauce.
And it's really that easy.
And this is something that
you can make a big batch of.
It freezes really well.
If you're into,
like, DIY stuff, you
can buy great tomatoes
right now at the farmers
market in New York, peel
them, make your own sort
of canned tomatoes.
But, that's it.
And it's as simple as that.
So these are gonna
go in the oven.
And that's how they'll cook.
I love those-- who
made the little one?
It's so cute.
That's great.
The only thing I'm gonna do
before I put them in the oven
is just drizzle them with
a little bit more olive
oil on top, because basically
fat helps things brown.
Also makes things delicious.
So a little olive oil will help.
And there's-- I
forgot to mention,
there's olive oil rubbed on a
piece of parchment on this pan,
which again will just
help them release.
Basically anything that makes
your life easier in the kitchen
is great by me.
So that's the purpose of that.
It also makes cleanup
easier, because you
don't have, like, that burned,
like, turkey stuff on the pan
once it's done.
So, a little drizzle.
And then we're
gonna roast these.
And then once
they're cooked, we'll
pop them in the tomato sauce.
OK.
Awesome.
So I'm gonna stick them in here.
I think we're at 425, which
is I feel like a temperature
I tend to do a lot of things at.
And we're gonna cook them for--
I can't remember how long.
I think like 20, 25 minutes.
But you just sort of check them.
I'm gonna check this to see what
I told you, because-- let's see
if I'm right.
Oh, yeah.
About 25 minutes.
That's good.
And-- but I'll probably
check them around 20.
And since we have two
trays, in 10 minutes,
I'm just gonna flip them,
just so they cook really nice
and evenly.
And then we'll pop them in here.
And those are turkey
and ricotta balls.
And they're one of
my favorite things.
And I hope you enjoy them.
And so that you don't have
to wait for 20 minutes,
we have some already cooked.
And they're bubbling
away right by Deborah.
And we also have some
pasta, because I just
feel like there's nothing better
than meatballs on spaghetti.
But these are also
something that
like-- I love, like, a big
bowl of, like, something
like really garlicky,
broccoli rabe
next to a pile of meatballs.
It's like a little
healthier, it's
a little lighter
if you're trying
to avoid things like carbs.
But if you're not,
then you can just
eat this all to yourself, which
is what I would love to do.
And they're also really
delicious on polenta or rice.
Anything that's
gonna help absorb
that sauce is really, like,
gonna be your friend here.
Maybe like a piece of garlicky
toast or something like that.
But I really feel like if
you know how to make these,
you just like-- it means you
have this really great, like,
home-cooked thing in your
fridge waiting for you
when you get home from work.
You guys all work,
like, super hard.
You work at one of
the busiest places.
And I feel like taking the
time to make something homemade
just-- it's a really-- I think
it's a sort of like empowering
thing to do, and
it's like-- it's
a nice kind of self-care moment,
or great for your family.
So those are the meatballs.
So I would love-- maybe we
could have people try them,
if that works out.
And-- oh yeah, and
I would love to know
if you have any questions about
meatballs, cookbooks, anything.
Yeah, please.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The tomato sauce--
JULIA TURSHEN: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: --it was-- oh.
The tomato sauce, when
you ad made it before,
like you kind of
crushed it beforehand.
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you
add anything special
to that, like any herbs or--
JULIA TURSHEN: Nothing.
AUDIENCE: --do all
the herbs going into--
JULIA TURSHEN: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: --the meatball itself?
JULIA TURSHEN:
Into the meatball.
Sometimes I like to,
like-- that moment when
you add the tomatoes to the
hot sort of garlicky oil,
sometimes I like to throw,
like, one or two whole sprigs
of fresh basil.
Just the whole thing.
Like, you don't
even take them off.
And just let it cook
as the sauce cooks.
And then I pull
it out at the end,
and it gives like a
really nice flavor.
But you can-- I mean,
if you want other herbs,
like, you could put,
like, finely-chopped thyme
or rosemary.
Any of those kinds
of, like, woody herbs.
And this sauce also can go in
a lot of different directions.
Like if I'm making-- like
those sort of North African
meatballs I was talking
about, like with the cumin
and stuff, sometimes I'll put
a cinnamon stick in the oil,
and then add the tomatoes.
And it, like-- it's
one ingredient,
but it makes it this
whole different thing.
And it just gives it this whole
new, like, layer of flavor.
So that's a really
nice thing to do.
But this is kind of
like the baseline.
And then you can go anywhere.
AUDIENCE: And sorry, I
have one more question.
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah, please.
Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if
you're not going to,
like, kind of professionally
can it, jar it, afterwards--
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah.
Don't need to do that, yeah.
AUDIENCE: How long
would that stay good?
JULIA TURSHEN: I would say it
would stay good for definitely
at least like a
week in the fridge.
And if you don't want to do the
canning and jarring and stuff,
I highly recommend just putting
it like in a quart-size Ziploc
or-- you know, whatever brand
of plastic bag you like.
And then freeze it.
And when I do-- I do that with
soups a lot, and tomato sauce.
And I put it in
the bag, and then I
lay it flat in the freezer.
And then once it's
frozen, you can kind of
stack them up and
make, like, files.
So you can have your,
like, super sauce filing
cabinet in the freezer.
It takes up, like,
a lot less space,
which is a premium in New York.
And it just makes
it really easy also.
You can do it in a
smaller-sized bag,
and then you can pull
out-- like if you're just
cooking for yourself or just
one or two other people,
like, you don't have to defrost,
like, this huge thing just
to get, like, a little bit.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks.
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah, of course.
Thank you.
KAREN: For those of us
who don't cook a lot--
JULIA TURSHEN: Come over.
KAREN: What do you
recommend starting with?
What are some good
recipes to begin with?
JULIA TURSHEN: That's
a great question.
I think this is a really
good recipe mostly just
because they're delicious
and they're, like,
pretty easy to make, and you
can make such a big batch,
as I was talking about.
I think I may have--
oh no, it's on.
Sorry.
There's also-- it really
depends on what you like to eat.
I think if you-- you know,
if you enjoy chicken,
there's a roast chicken in
"Small Victories," which
is kind of like--
there's a roast
chicken in every cookbook, I
know, but this one I really
believe in so much
because it sort of teaches
you all these great techniques
that aren't techniques,
they're just easy.
Like, I'm thinking about
taking the chicken out
so it's at room temperature
before it goes in the oven,
so you're not putting this
ice-cold thing in a hot oven
and, like, why
isn't this cooking.
So it's like doing a
simple thing like that
will make a big difference.
It's got a really
nice mix of, like,
salt and rosemary
and lemon and garlic
and just all the things you
want with a roast chicken.
So that's a really
great place to start.
And I feel like
roasting a chicken is
kind of like-- I feel like if
you can do that in the kitchen
to get started, it makes you
feel like you can kind of do
anything.
But if you're
vegetarian, obviously
don't roast the chicken,
because that would probably
make you really bummed out.
So yeah, it really
totally depends
on what you want to eat.
But I would say those two are
my favorite starting points.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: You brought
it up before--
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Space is a premium.
So my kitchen is about 1/30
the size of this countertop.
Do you have any small victories
or strategies or tools--
JULIA TURSHEN: For sure.
AUDIENCE: --for really,
really tiny spaces.
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah.
I-- so I now live
in upstate New York.
We kind of live in
the middle of nowhere.
And I now have a big kitchen.
But prior to that, I lived in
a series of studio apartments
in New York, and very
rarely had a counter,
you know-- like this, to
me, is a lot of space.
I didn't have that
for a long time.
But I have worked on
cookbooks and I've
tested cookbooks in apartments
with that kind of counter.
So I've done a lot of cooking
in really small spaces.
I think a few things.
One, a folding table
is an awesome thing.
And I have set up
many in-- you know,
whatever space is
near my kitchen
when I'm doing a lot
of cooking, because I
think you don't really need
much more space than this.
Like, you can't chop much
more than this at a time.
But my problem was always
like, oh, I cut up these onions
or whatever, I'm putting
them in a bowl to use,
and then where do
I put that bowl.
So like having that extra
space somewhere-- the top
of the fridge is a really
nice spot for that.
But I think having
a small space really
forces you to be organized.
And to me, cooking
in New York was
all about kind of shopping
for just what I needed
for that specific
thing, and not getting
overwhelmed with so much
on the counter or anything.
And I think the other
thing is like-- I mean,
I love a blender.
I love, you know, I love
a gadget here or there,
but I really don't think
they're all that necessary.
I honestly think if you
have a few good mixing
bowls and a pot
and a good knife,
like, you can make anything.
And like, I don't think
you need that many gadgets
or electronics, like,
on the kitchen counter.
So that would be my advice,
is just to kind of pare down.
And you can make a lot.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell us more about how
you got into this field?
JULIA TURSHEN: Sure, yeah.
So I have cooked since, like,
well before I can remember.
I can't-- I like truly
can't remember a time when I
wasn't cooking.
When I met Karen, when we were
eight, I was already into food.
And I had just always loved it.
It's been my passion.
And the thing I've also
really loved is writing,
and I always loved
English classes.
And my parents both
worked in publishing,
so it always felt very
familiar and comfortable to me
to be near magazines
and books and sort
of printed matter, which
is fascinating to be here
at Google.
But I always loved
combining my love of food
with my love of writing.
And at whatever age
when you start writing,
like, book reports, like middle
school, that kind of-- like I
wrote about, like,
what Huck Finn ate.
Like, it was always about food.
I was always writing about food.
And then I went to college
in New York on the Upper West
Side.
I went to Barnard.
And being in New
York, as you all know,
kind of gives you this
sort of entry point
to lots of things
that you might not
have access to in other places.
So I started interning-- I was
an intern at "Food and Wine
Magazine" for a year.
I worked for this great
guy who produces food
shows for public television.
I just kind of got my
foot in as many food doors
as I could, and then
worked really hard to stay
on the other side
of those doors.
And the guy who produced
all the public television
shows, he worked on that show
"Spain-- On the Road Again."
And you mentioned the
first book I worked on
was called "Spain:
A Culinary Road
Trip," which was the
companion book to that show.
And so that was really
my starting point.
And then it was kind of
one thing led to another
and my-- I feel like the best
way I can describe my career
is that I've never
written a resume.
It's all word of mouth.
It's all sort of
personal relationships.
And to me, that's kind
of the spirit of food.
It's, like, about sharing, you
know, just these great things
with other people.
So that's been that,
and it's a fun road.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
meeting your wife
through a meatball recipe.
Do you have any other
fun date night recipes--
JULIA TURSHEN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: --that kind
of get you excited?
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah.
I think-- that's so funny.
So I'm trying to think.
Like, I think one
really great thing to do
is to cook together, if both
you and the person you are,
you know, having a romance
with enjoy cooking.
That can be really fun, to
just kind of have an activity.
And then you're-- like, you're
making something together.
And that's really nice.
And it's nice to sit
down and be like, oh, we
both, like, invested this
time into doing that.
You know, you can both
roll out the meatballs.
Like, whatever works.
And-- but also, if
the person you're with
doesn't enjoy cooking, it
really can be such a gift
to cook for someone.
Or if you don't
really like cooking,
you can just kind
of, like, gently push
a cookbook toward their
way and make a suggestion.
And maybe they like cooking.
Because I think cooking is just
the best way to show someone
you really care about them.
It's been my means of
doing that my whole life.
And it can be simple.
It can be, like, a sandwich that
someone takes to the office.
Like, I really believe cooking
doesn't have to be over the top
to be just meaningful,
by any means.
So some good things
to make at home,
there's a recipe in
"Small Victories"
for-- if you like fish,
it's a really easy recipe.
And it's basically you take
a sheet pan, like the one
we had the meatballs
on, and you put either
chopped tomatoes or cherry
tomatoes, a little garlic
and oil, roast it, and make
this kind of roasted tomato,
like, base.
And then you put some, like--
I use flounder in the book,
but any kind of flat, thin fish
that will cook sort of quickly.
And you put that on top
of the roasted tomatoes.
You put, like, a little
bit of olive oil.
And I put some olives,
because I love them,
but you can leave them out.
And you just put that
back in the oven.
And it takes, like, 10 minutes.
And it's like this--
it's really like-- it's
kind of like a really elegant
dish, but it's so easy.
And it's like you're not
dealing with, like, searing fish
in a hot pan and
it's gonna overcook
and it's gonna make your
apartment smell like a seafood
restaurant for a week.
There's also another fish
that's wrapped in parchment
and has something
called chermoula,
which is the sort of North
African kind of-- sort
of like a pesto.
It's got, like,
cilantro and cumin
and those kinds of flavors.
That's really nice
because, again, you're
not dealing with, like, smoky
fish stuff in a small space.
And those two are, like, pretty
quick to put together, and kind
of just like a little bit
elevate-- like, I don't know,
making fish at home always feels
like a little special to me.
And so I feel like
for a date kind
of thing, that would be great.
And if you don't like
fish, I just-- I really
always go back to
the roast chicken.
I just think it's
the best thing.
AUDIENCE: So I'll ask one more.
So, favorites.
Because, like, I suppose you
don't always eat your own food,
so do you have any favorite
restaurants in New York City?
JULIA TURSHEN: Sure, yeah.
Yeah.
My friend Mario Batali, who I
know is coming to do an event,
I think, at some point?
He has a line that I love,
which is his favorite thing
to eat is anything
anyone else makes.
So I totally get that.
My-- now that I don't live in
the city, when I-- it's sort of
helped me feel very
clear about the places
I do love to come to, because my
time here is much more limited
than it used to be.
And honestly, the
three restaurants
I love more than anything
are very close by.
They're Buvette, Via Corota,
and I Sodi, and Buvette.
Full disclosure, I worked
on the "Buvette" book,
so I'm totally biased,
but so happily biased.
And Jody Williams runs Buvette.
She's amazing.
She's one of the funniest
people in the world.
She's so talented.
It's a little-- if you
haven't been there, it's tiny.
It's nothing like Google.
It's this big.
And it's basically like
stepping into, like,
a little slice of Paris.
It's really special.
It's like a very sort
of-- you feel transported,
which is I think one
of the best things you
can feel in a restaurant.
And you can go there any
time of day, which is great.
So you can get, like, a little
breakfast or just a coffee,
you can have a full
meal if you want.
I just think it's
really special.
And then Jody's partner
in life and business
runs I Sodi, which I think-- I
hate to tell a big group this,
because it's already
hard to get into,
but I think it's the best
restaurant in New York.
It's the most amazing
Italian restaurant.
It's on Christopher Street.
And then together they run
Via Corota on Grove Street.
And I just think they put their
heart into everything they do,
and they just kind of embody
the spirit of hospitality.
They really make you
feel taken care of.
And their food is
just delicious.
So those are my three go-tos.
And you can go to all
of them in one night,
because they're all right there.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
What do you think
of the meatballs?
Good?
Yeah?
Awesome.
OK.
Cool.
That's great to hear.
That's great.
I have a good Google story.
Is it OK if I tell that?
Because I was thinking
about coming here and ways--
because I was
talking about, like,
loving print so
much, but also, like,
Google has really changed my
life as a cookbook author.
I'm not just saying that.
And one of the ways I was
thinking that has happened
is-- I'm really bad
with time, but I
guess a couple years
ago I was working on,
and maybe it came out a year
or two ago, a book called
"The Hot Bread
Kitchen" cookbook.
And Hot Bread Kitchen is
this amazing organization.
It's like a workforce
development program.
It's based in Harlem.
They sell at the farmers'
markets and Whole Foods in New
York, all different places.
They supply some restaurants.
It's a wholesale bakery.
But it's completely
employed by sort
of immigrant and
low-income women.
And they get
on-the-job training.
They also get business classes,
English as second language
classes, all that
kind of amazing staff.
And they're basically
graduated from the program
to go on to take management
positions in other bakeries
and sort of cooking
places in New York,
or start their own
businesses, which is awesome.
And when I was-- and oh, the
other great part about it
is they-- everything they
make is inspired by the women,
or recipes are
contributed by them.
So they have the most sort of
eclectic, interesting, amazing
roster of things.
So they make, like, the best
Jewish challah and bialys,
but they also make, like,
incredible tortillas
and Moroccan flatbreads.
Like it's-- they're amazing.
So when I was
working on that book,
it was sort of me communicating
with all these different women
trying to get their
recipes written,
trying to get all
these stories down.
And there was definitely, at
certain points, a real language
barrier.
And it's kind of
amazing how much
you can communicate with food
without actually talking.
So that was, like, interesting.
But I, like, could not
have done that book
without Google Translate.
And I am so grateful for it.
And to me, it was such
an interesting moment
of, like, wow, this, like--
this is making this so possible.
And it was so clear
to me in that moment.
And when I was on
my way here today,
I was just thinking, that would
be a good story to tell here.
So thank you, whoever
works on Translate.
Oh my god, that's amazing.
I feel like this
is good if you run.
I mean, like, I've heard about
carbo loading and stuff, so.
Anyway, any other questions?
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming, by the way.
This is amazing.
JULIA TURSHEN: Oh, I'm
so glad you liked it.
AUDIENCE: I was interested--
you've obviously
worked with a lot of
really famous chefs.
Who's-- who would be somebody
that you haven't worked with
yet that you'd be really
interested in collaborating
with in the future?
JULIA TURSHEN: That's
a great question.
I-- gotta think about
this for a second.
There's a few that come to mind,
and they're both in the south.
And my wife Grace who
we were talking about
is from Virginia, so there's
part of me that, like, feels
very drawn towards the south.
Maybe it's from that.
But one does not need
my help whatsoever.
And her name is Vivian Howard.
She has a PBS show.
She has her own book, I think
it's coming out in October.
It's amazing.
I got to see a little
sneak peek of it.
But I think her
approach to food is
just-- it's so from the heart.
And she's just such
a talented chef
on top of that sort of really
deep, emotional connection
to food.
So I guess maybe I wouldn't
want to work with her,
because I don't
think she needs that.
But I guess I would just like
to spend more time with her.
And the other is this great
guy who I don't really know,
but I had one conversation with.
And his name is Ed Mitchell, and
he is based in North Carolina.
And I don't know if any
of you read or watched
the I guess Netflix version
maybe of Michael Pollan's
"Cooked."
And he-- Michael spent a lot
of time with Ed Mitchell.
And Ed Mitchell does whole
hog BBQ, which is hard to say,
in North Carolina.
And he learned from his
father and his grandfather,
and it's passed down.
And he just-- I feel like he
has so many amazing stories
to tell.
And I think those
stories are so important,
and I think a cookbook
is a great place
to store those kinds
of stories, and a way
to just be able to
interact with them, too.
Because not only do you
get to tell them-- like,
I got to tell you about,
like, oh I met Grace
and I fell in love and I made
her meatballs, but also like,
here, you can make
the meatballs, too.
So I feel like Ed has these
really incredible stories that
are just so much
about his family,
but also kind of the
history of America.
And it's-- they're
important, so I think--
I hope those get written down.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JULIA TURSHEN: Yeah, of course.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Do you have any food that
you hate working with,
or any ingredients
but you know they're
fan favorites so you
have to work with them anyway?
JULIA TURSHEN: Great question.
I really like-- I feel like I
don't really dislike any food.
And Grace was poking
fun at me yesterday
because I-- I can't even
remember what I was eating,
and I was like, oh,
god, I love this,
this is the best
thing I ever had.
And she's like, you say
that about everything.
[LAUGHS] everything?
Is the best thing you ever had.
So I really-- there's
not much I don't like.
But I guess-- I
feel like the thing
I do try to avoid and try
to avoid using in recipes,
but also just eating, is
just, like, super processed
food, just things like I
don't really understand.
And I definitely have a soft
spot for, like, a Cool Ranch
Dorito or something
like that, but like-- I
feel like those are the kinds
of products I try not to use.
And also, it just comes
from-- I feel very strongly
about writing recipes
that anyone can replicate,
no matter where they are.
And asking for a very
particular brand of something
is something I
always try not to do,
unless I really have a
reason for doing that.
And if I do, I'll always give
you, like, a substitution,
because-- just because-- you
know, it's hard in New York,
because you can find anything,
but in a lot of places,
you can't.
So.
But I would say anything
like super, super processed.
Any other questions?
No?
Cook.
Well, this was super fun.
And I hope you guys
try the meatballs
and maybe try some variations.
And I guess the
only thing I forgot
to mention is my sort of
fantasy with "Small Victories"
and offering all the variations
and riffs on the recipes
is I can't wait to
see what people make,
but like-- you know, it's
inspired by the recipe,
but isn't the recipe.
Like, I just-- I
feel like I put-- I
tried to be as creative as I
possibly could, but I think
there's something
about cookbooks
and how people
participate with them
and try them on their
own that makes it
this kind of
collaborative thing.
So if you have any other
ideas for meatball riffs,
I'd love to know them.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
hashtag or anything?
JULIA TURSHEN: Oh,
hashtag-- hashtag?
Smallvictoriescookbook.
And that's it.
Cool.
Thank you all so much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]